哈喽哈喽，各位听众朋友们，大家好，我是老潘。欢迎回到FOTORIZON新一期的节目。这是一档贩摄影谈话类节目，我们希望摆脱故作高深的艺术术语，不做求真求智的教科书，只想和大家聊聊有关摄影的一切。本期节目将由我和白熊和阿兴一起来聊一聊如何自学摄影这个话题。
那么先跟大家打个招呼吧。
哈喽大家好，我是白熊。
哈喽哈喽大家好，我是阿兴。
好的，那么在开启今天的节目之前的话呢，还要先特别感谢一下在我们之前的Q&A特级中提问的三位朋友。
因为他们的提问呢，才有了今天这些节目，那么他们是秒数五厘米，然后坤还有咕噜。
那么他们三位的问题呢，其实都是涉及到如何去学习摄影，尤其是如何去自学摄影的这样子一个大问题。
所以我们今天呢，就从这个话题切入来跟大家聊一聊。
那首先的话呢，其实我有两个问题想要跟阿兴和白熊一起去探讨一下。
那第一个问题的话呢，就是你们是如何看待学习摄影这件事情的。
或者换句话说，你们觉得摄影需要学习吗？
因为我自己不是在小红书上会分享一些我在马格兰学摄影的一些经验吗？
然后我就记得有一条留言，我印象特别深刻。
就有一位朋友他就给我留言，他说如果摄影需要学习，我宁可放弃。
就是某种程度上说，我们觉得现在关于摄影是不是需要学习这件事情是有一定争议的。
至少从这条留言来看啊，是有这样的一个争议。
我不知道你们怎么看这个问题。
我不是很懂他的点，为什么他认为如果要学就要放弃呢？
他是觉得只要按快门就行的吗？
或者他觉得摄影是一个有关于天赋的东西，是不需要去学习的。
就这个每个人的想法可能不一样的。
我觉得可能他是从这个角度，他觉得摄影其实是天生的。
就你天生有这个摄影眼你就有，如果你没有就没有。
我觉得他可能是在这个角度去。
但是退一万步讲啊，像我我办公室的同事，因为他平时要那个售卖一些器材吗？
他会在跟别人交谈的时候，人家会跟他说一些相机上的东西。
但是他连A党，M党，P党是什么都不知道。
他连ISO啊，光圈啊，这种东西都是不知道的。
我觉得最基本的说你像机上的这些东西参数什么你得去搞明白。
那这个就是一个学习的过程。
我觉得不存在说不需要学习。
如果你单纯只是说用手机拍那OK你去不用去管，
因为手机会帮你都调好。
但是你真的想说要拿相机开始拍了那你相机上的这些东西按钮啊，
这个就是学习的第一步。
因为老潘刚刚说的这个话让我觉得有点像另外一种说法就是学做人。
很多人就说你天生生下来就是做人。
为什么还要去学习怎么做人呢？
我觉得这个就是一种一样的道理。
摄影它这是一个大话题。
你不仅仅是说拿这个工具去固定下一个画面这么一个事情。
它当中涉及到了很多内容。
所以说我觉得学习摄影就是一个就是一个完全需要的一个事情。
并不是说你天生就对于所有的事情都非常擅长。
学习并不仅仅就是说是从0到1可能就是从1再更往上吧。
我觉得有这么一种感觉。
因为我还看到过一个博主啊。
我觉得他拍的还不错其实。
他的标题就是说从来没有学过摄影的我是怎么拍照的。
然后下面就会有很多人留言说摄影确实是不要学习的。
摄影就是天赋怎么怎么样。
但是我其实跟阿星和白老师的看法是一致的。
我觉得摄影是一定要学习的。
首先就像阿星和白老师说的一样。
摄影是一个介于技术和艺术之间的事情。
它有机器这样子的一个固定的客观存在。
你必须要学习如何去使用这个机器。
哪怕你看说明书它也是一种学习嘛。
你学习如何使用这个器材。
或者学习是如何使用这个镜头。
在教片时代你学习如何去使用教片如何去冲起教片。
这些东西都是需要去学习的。
这是第一点。
然后第二点我觉得就是在摄影中天赋其实不是决定因素。
我现在看到的越来越多的摄影师甚至于一些特别好的摄影师。
他们其实在天赋上都并不是特别出众。
就真正决定他们的成就的反而是努力。
这个努力其实就包括努力去学习然后努力去拍摄。
努力去做到尽可能做的更好。
我觉得与其天赋来说好像在摄影上努力更重要。
那老潘我想问你一下。
你觉得什么样的天赋可以被用在摄影这方面？
我觉得很难说吧当然如果审美是一种天赋的话确实有天身审美就比较好的人。
那他肯定在这方面是占优势的。
那其实天赋还有很多种比如说你的天赋就是你能够很好的组织你的拍摄。
就是你有很强的这种项目的执行能力我觉得这也是一种天赋。
或者你的天赋是沟通和表达你能够很容易的在拍摄过程中去接近你的拍摄对象。
跟他们形成比较良好的互动关系。
或者你的天赋是语言。
其实各种各样的天赋都可以在摄影之间事情中产生作用。
因为就像阿星刚说的摄影它是一个很大的一个话题。
它并不仅仅是按下快门这一个瞬间。
它可能是摄影之前的准备摄影之中的拍摄摄影之后的一些东西。
甚至于你的天赋是去营销自己。
它其实都是可能去给你的摄影提供帮助的东西吧。
比如说你甚至这边天赋是特别擅长运动。
哪怕说是攀岩，我还有一个朋友就是他是特别会攀岩特别会爬山。
然后很多照片确确实实是如果你并不擅长这些的话根本就拍不到的。
对是的是的。
我刚才想到天赋的这个词我想到就是你对什么事情特别敏感。
嗯是。
我觉得它这个就是你的一个天赋所在。
然后我觉得摄影又是一个比较万金油的东西。
它可以和很多东西结合在一起。
然后我在想你擅长的你敏感的特别敏感的那个领域然后再跟摄影结合在一起。
可能就是一条你自己的赛道。
没错没错没错。
就是对但是天赋它依然不是一个决定性因素。
就哪怕你有这些天赋你还是需要经过努力和学习的。
而且还有一点我觉得就是摄影为什么说我觉得摄影需要学习是因为摄影是可以学会的。
就有一些东西你可能是真的学不太会或者说是比如说数学题。
对对对我来说数学题我就学不会我就我就从来数学就没考几个锅。
对但摄影是可以学会的因为我自己就是一个很好的例子就是我从来都不觉得自己是一个特别特别有天赋的人。
然后我也不敢说我现在学的很好啊但是我至少觉得通过学习是可以有进步的是可以去掌握一定的技能。
然后是可以去学会这件事情哪怕是入个门它是可以做到的。
所以既然这件事情可以通过学习来获得那为什么不去学一学呢。
然后那既然我们的这个观点都是摄影是可以是需要去学习的那下一个问题的话呢就是我们要讨论一下摄影可不可以自学。
肯定是可以的。举双手双脚说肯定是可以的。
结合我个人的例子我是在有第一台相机之前我其实自己已经花了很长一段将近一年的时间去看网上的各种照片去看参数。
因为我其实当时很怕你花了那么多钱要将近一万块的设备你买了之后。
就三天大约两天下网就不喜欢了因为我也不确定自己的喜欢能持续多久。
那我就可以先持续学嘛因为学习的成本是很低的因为网上的资源特别多。
你只要经常去刷一些论坛看一些帖子看一些操作视频等等你可以先学起来。
然后等你确定了说如果你在学习上都能保持这样的一段热情。
那你拿有了相机之后会会更想着要出去拍。
所以我在结合了自己的经验的时候我是先学习再买了器材。
哦对我记得白老师说这个还挺神奇的就是你在没有相机的时候你就已经开始去学习摄影这件事情了。
这个好像跟很多人的经历都不太一样。
因为器材太贵了买不起所以先学吧学学看。
我与筹谋。
学得下去再买呗。
万一学不下去了我就不买了正好也生一笔钱。
然后学着学着发现确实是喜欢的那就买呗正好也花时间充电钱。
这也是通过这方式来确认自己的摄影有没有兴趣？
是的是的。
那阿兴呢？
白老师他有意识去学习我反过来就是没有任何学习的这个意识。
我拿到相机之后就是我也知道要提升自己的照片就是拍摄更多的拍摄然后提高自己的照片的画质也好内容也好。
我没有考虑过去所谓的就是学习打影号的这个学习。
但是实际上在所有的过程当中都是在学习就是我认为这在提升自己。
但是每一步比如说我去了解相机怎么操作的从A党学习到M党或者说提升自己的审美去看更多不同的风格的照片也好这些东西其实都是在学习。
虽然说没有刻意的去强调比如说去报班去查找什么课程或者说是什么教程并没有任何的花费吧跟白老师一样。
我觉得是挺感谢互联网的因为现在很多东西你都可以在互联网上得到。
就不像以前没有网络的时候你如果真的要学你我能想到的就是可能去图书馆借本书对吧。
哪怕说你现在找朋友啊找人一起交流听他们讲其实也是一个学习的过程。
没错没错就是学习这件事情他可能不是一个说我必须得坐下来我说我打开了学习这个模式我才能开始学的。
他很多时候尤其是兴趣上的学习可能是在一种潜于默化中去进行的就是在你日常的积累中慢慢去获得就像阿欣说的一样。
对所以摄影是可以自学的对吧所以我我的观点跟大家也是一样的就是我觉得摄影也是可以自学的。
然后我的经历跟你们两位可能稍微有一点点不同就是我最开始有相机的时候其实并没有任何学习摄影的概念就是我没有想过说我要去学习。
就是我那会儿就真的是有了一台相机之后呢就是出去旅行的时候去玩的时候拍一点照片然后把照片导出来然后犀利花拉的去弄一下。
就我也没有想过说我想去看一看别人是怎么拍的或者说是想看一看这个参数是什么样子的唯一的那个阶段的学习可能就是研究相机研究镜头研究器材本身然后我是到了拍了。
我觉得停下来这样也是一种学习啊对其实也是用到研究两个字了对其实也是就是那个时候就是对器材特别感兴趣嘛。
我记得我用的那个时候还是尼康的这种半幅机器然后就研究说哎这个机器上用什么镜头会比较好这个镜头能出什么样的效果然后这个镜头怎么跟那个镜头比起来怎么样。
然后我记得那个时候有什么1685然后啊我就是这个我就是这个对吧1685还是什么175是不是我记得哦对对对对对对对对有一些在变焦头里面还比较好的镜头然后他们就会给他们起名字嘛。
说哪只镜头叫什么名字然后这只镜头有一个自己的名字就觉得还挺酷的然后那会的主要的经历就是在研究这个东西。
嗯然后一直到了过了几年之后我才想着说哎我可能想要在摄影这件事情上再往前走一点然后我就给自己定了一个学习计划虽然也是自学啊就定了一个学习计划来去做这件事情。
才开始认真的去说从各方面去对摄影进行一个相对来说自己觉得有系统性的学习。
但这个也是和我的习惯有关我很难去零散的做事情。
所以我基本上做任何事情都会有规划然后会有一个小小的计划去做就很是叫屁人吗。
这人这人啊这人是吧屁人屁人是没什么规划。
ok就我还是蛮有规划的所以我是这样子的一个过程。
但是通过我自己的经历的话我就觉得摄影是我可以自学的。
但是自学在某个阶段可能会到达一个瓶颈这个我可能就是不是我们今天会去讨论的一个话题了。
我们就不管他我们就继续往下聊那下一个部分的话呢我们可以来一起讨论一下就是在自学摄影的时候我们是怎么去自学。
那我觉得可能要分个阶段啊一个是在入门阶段一个是在线阶段或者是一个我们可以叫进阶的阶段进步的阶段。
那我们还从入门开始在入门阶段两位是怎么样开始自学摄影是怎么做的做了那些事情。
我入门阶段就是我买相机之前就就开始入门。
那时候先你就就搞清楚那些关系嘛。
是ISO是什么然后光圈是什么快门速度又是什么p.a.m.s.都都会适合用在哪些场景下面。
然后去大量的去看样片然后看那种对比图就改变一个参数其他参数不变能得到什么样的效果。
对这个是非常入门你需要知道的东西然后稍微再往前走一点。
你就会知道长曝光是需要什么能拍出什么对战是什么可以获得什么效果间隔拍摄是什么。
可以出什么效果然后知道了之后你就一定要去实践因为我觉得摄影是一个非常需要落地的东西。
你不能说啊我看了我脑子会了但是手还是不会的你还是得哦长曝光原来要要比如说你要配个脚架呢。
买个脚架然后就出去拍拍车轨也好拍星空也好就是都是在学习和试措的过程。
因为一开始的两三张其实是会是拍失败的然后拍失败的时候你就开始想哎呀我这个参数是不是这边。
什么快门再慢一点光圈再小一点大一点我要怎么调然后再拍了和在错误之后然后你会得到一张哦还是可以的照片。
然后包括对战也是嗯对战可能前期你就要把步骤先都学好学好之后你到现场去拍比如说去拍音火虫大概要拍几张怎么设置弄好然后回到家来。
然后但是也会有失败啊失败之后你就还会还会再去第二次在换一个地方去拍音火虫就是是一个学习然后发现错误然后再去尝试的这样的一个过程。
包括间隔拍摄也是你要拍一个日出你间隔拍摄一开始我记得我拍的时候设成了M档然后。
嗯然后就就没有调整然后就后面的那个曝光都是错误的然后就发现哦那对然后你就知道哦那下次你要去拍的时候你要怎么操作就是一个。
拍了哦发现错误然后再去拍这样的要有一个实际性的落地的操作的过程而不是只是看人家怎么拍然后以及包括在进阶道说。
因为摄影还会有很多配件比如说是买ND镜买偏镇镜还有哦还有闪光灯都是。
就是很多这些配件加上去之后会附带给你很多拍摄的一些乐趣一些新的拍的东西那就是一个在不断学习。
就是从入门到经济的各样的一个过程所以白老师你在入门的时候的学习是基于花钱。
就是我就钱花下去了我买了三小架我的眼睛就怎么。
花配件上对对花配件上我买了这个ND镜我该怎么办买了闪光灯我该怎么办。
嗯那你买了ND镜就势必说要去拍风光拍长保的风光这种。
嗯然后你就会啊好走出去拍这次旅行就带这个了然后然后拍的不好当时拍的时候哎啊这个怎么会这样然后就开始。
开始就是你的基础知识就是你的那些曝光嗯快门呃那个那个ISO嘛光圈快门ISO你就开始想怎么调怎么调。
对所以白老师你是相当于是说在实践之中去去获得这个入门的学习的。
是的是的我觉得摔影就是一个要落地的过程不是啊我电脑上看一看好我学会了。
这样不行对对对还是不知道操作上时候手忙脚乱。
那阿兴呢你在入门的阶段是怎么自学的呀。
我现在回看起来好像是能够分得出来自己是到什么时候被拦在入门的那个阶段啊就是技术上全部达标了吧。
我觉得跟白老师特别像就是把自己放在拍摄的环境当中去沉浸式的提升和自学。
就是白老师说的配件这个事情我也非常认同就是把所有的包括相机啊把所有的配件就是基础的可以用的都去用一遍。
当然钱是不可避免的要花掉了。
但是你所有的配件包括nd或者三角架用过一遍就知道当中有哪些就是新影的拍摄方式甚至。
其实更加进阶一些的但我觉得还是属于入门的比如说呃用吃到鱼啊这些都去尝试一下。
去拍出那些平时呃不知道怎么会出来的一些照片。
当所有的技术全部落地了以后你知道就是什么样的照片怎么拍了我觉得这时候在摄影当中就算是入门了。
换一个嗯怎么说呢可能大家更好说更好理解的例子比如说举个例子魔兽世界。
就像是人说的只有满级了才算是游戏的开始就是你刚刚可以开始去享受摄影这件事情了才能继续网上啊。
那对前面都是打打怪升级的就像我最早我当时刚开始拍照的时候。
其实我的相机储存卡里面最多的照片是我的桌子还有小区里面的这个非常重复单调的。
为什么是桌子？
因为我一直在桌子前面摆那种相机啊就是看着说明书一直不同的挡位不同的参数去拍。
到底是怎么样子的我要拍一张才能知道啊原来真的是这样子的如果光看说明书可能还不够。
摄影就跟把老师刚刚说的一定要落地到实际上的操作。
就是你不去真正的按下这个快门去在画面中看到这个前一后果你可能还不是记得很清楚。
然后我学校里面的那个风树叶也是被不同的参数不同的相机拍了几百张照片。
对
然后说到审美
其实在第一次参与录制播客的时候有提到过。
当时我的审美其实是跟着不同的加入的摄影群走的。
就是比如说当时加入了那个QQ群。
里面就是老法师
然后就是完全就是照着他们的风格也会去拍。
然后不同的风格都去走一遍了。
然后看一看
感觉这个高级去试一试。
那个觉得好厉害
也去跟着他的那个风格去走一走。
然后都走过了
都试过了
相机的每一个参数。
每一种模式还有配件都试过了。
都玩过了
我觉得这个时候可以说自己算是入门了。
所以相当于是说从模仿开始。
是
其实我也试的
我在刚开始学审美。
就是买相机的一两年里面。
有一个朋友就会问我说。
你就算不能每天拍照。
那你每天看照片吗？
还是这么问我
所以就是相当于说是。
你们会在初期阶段会把注意力放在技术上。
然后除此之外的话。
就是去通过看别人拍的照片。
就像阿欣比如说在不同的摄影群里。
然后白老师看不同的照片。
然后看到这个好的。
或者说哪怕不一定是好的。
就这个阶段
就我对这种照片感兴趣。
我就去模仿
尝试我的技术
能不能实现这个照片。
可以这么理解吧？
可以这么理解
对
然后我自己的话
可能有一点不太一样。
但是我也是把钱花下去的。
除了这个设备和配件之外。
我从决定了我要学摄影这件事情开始。
就像我刚说的
我从最开始那个阶段。
其实是没有学习这个概念的。
除了对器材的兴趣之外。
好像对于其他的学习。
都没有一个非常明确的说。
我想要去学
但是到了某一天开始。
我觉得我想要在摄影之间。
是一双继续去进步一些的时候。
我就给自己设置了一个学习的计划。
所以我当时在技术之间事情上。
是报了一个课程的。
我报了纽约摄影学院的线上课。
我不知道大家知不知道。
扭射从建校开始
它是做寒寿的
后来寒寿这个东西没有了。
就变成了线上课
我当时尝试过买扭射的书。
但是我买了这个书之后。
我觉得我不太看得下去。
就觉得这个太无聊了。
我干脆就去他们的网站上。
找找看有没有其他的学习方法。
然后发现他们是有一套课程的。
是一套在线的课程。
通过文字加图片加视频的方式。
来教你摄影
然后我觉得还挺好的。
它也是一个
你可以自己给自己设置一个学习计划。
你在多长时间之内。
可以完成这个学习计划。
它会给你打分
会让你去完成一些小的作业。
然后你要去教作业。
教完作业之后
你会获得一个评价。
它其实是一个蛮好的自学的平台。
所以我当时就是报了这个课。
然后通过这个课程。
因为它会给你作业。
就可以迫使自己去多拍。
然后拍一些自己可能之前。
没有太在意过的主题。
或者说是没有太下过功夫的东西。
然后通过这个方式去打磨了一下技术。
让可以说通过这个课程之后。
不敢说别的
但是扭射的课程
我觉得还是教得挺好的。
基础打得挺扎实的。
它是知其然要知其所以然。
所以通过这个阶段。
对于技术的掌握就提高了不少。
然后在审美上
跟两位是一样的
就是看图片
那个时候有一些网站。
大家就会去分享图片。
我已经有点不记得了。
然后还有图库
什么图虫
然后500匹茶
这些也会去看一些。
他们不是也会
对 Lofter。
他们还会有一些比赛。
然后会有一些这种。
什么评比之类的
然后会推荐一些
他们觉得比较好的图片。
然后会通过这种方式。
去看一些图片
然后在这个阶段
我还有一个经验
也不算是经验
就是我自己的一个。
自学的时候的一个小的技巧。
就是我会去尝试
在初级阶段去获得一些成就感。
就是自学的反馈
因为既然是自学
就意味着你可能没有同学。
然后没有老师
你的成就感从哪里获得呢？
我当时就是通过图库。
我当时给自己设置一个目标。
大家比方说
我学习完这个扭射的课程。
那是半年时间之内。
我要去签约一个师学中国。
然后或者说是
在过多长时间
我要去签一个图虫。
通过这样子的一个。
或者是参加师学中国的一些比赛。
我还拿过什么500匹茶的新人王之类的。
特别
现在看起来特别幼稚的这个事情。
特别幼稚的这种比赛。
或者是这个
但是我觉得在你入门阶段的。
自学的过程中
会是一个很好的信心的提升。
然后会有很好的一个自学的反馈。
你能够看到自己学到哪儿了。
然后你的技术进步了。
然后别人可能会对你有什么样子的一个评价。
或者说是能够通过这样子。
一些小的态度
或者小的这个奖励。
能够让你去觉得
我的自学还不错
我可以继续下去
所以这是我在入门阶段所做的事情。
老潘我想问一下
那扭射
我听文奇名如雷贯。
我想问扭射到底会有些什么样的课程呢？
他的课程其实就特别入门。
他就是技术性的
对
他真的会从曝光三原则开始说。
然后他有一套自己的理念。
但我觉得这个理念很好。
比如说他有一个黄金三原则。
就说好的照片应该是简洁的。
好的照片应该是有主题的。
然后好的照片应该是可以帮助观众去吸引注意力的。
然后怎么样
他有一套这样子的一个给照片做的一个最基本的这么一个界定。
就到底好照片是什么？
然后接着的话呢？
他就有从基础上什么光圈快门感光度。
然后包括护衣率这些东西的基础技术。
然后一些场景拍摄的时候。
比如说灯光怎么设置。
然后不同的场景下有一些什么样的技巧。
他是一个他的那个课程叫做professional photographer。
就职业摄影或专业摄影师的在一个通识课。
然后这个课程之下就包含很多章节。
但是呢？
他涵盖了从最入门开始的技术需求的所有东西。
好
老潘快问快答一句话。
什么是好的照片
这个问题我觉得好像。
你学了扭车
就是他不是你刚才说嘛？
他会告诉你什么是好的照片。
那什么是好的照片一句话。
在那个时候我认同他的观点。
就是好的照片应该是有主题的。
在那个时候
但是现在我觉得我的观点好像有点不太一样。
对 没没事
那你说的这个主题。
他是需要一张图片表示。
还是说一组图片表示。
都是说而已
对于摄影师来说
就是你按下跨门之前。
你要知道自己拍什么？
这是一个很主观的事情。
但是我觉得
对 我觉得这点很重要。
但他的这个界定我觉得很好。
对吧？
所以他帮一个在入门阶段。
什么都不懂的人
去设置了一个最几百的框架。
告诉你在按下跨门之前。
你应该有思考
所以这个我觉得是扭车。
非常好的一点
这句话也是
因为我身边会碰到有人说。
哎呀 我有了相机间去拍什么呢？
好像出去晃了一圈。
什么都不知道
但这句话真的很重要。
你得知道自己要拍什么？
对的
所以我其实蛮推荐他的课程的。
我蛮推荐扭车的课程的。
就如果大家英语还不错。
因为他是全英文的。
就如果你英语还可以的话。
你可以去试试看这个课程。
如果你现在正在入门的阶段。
你对于学习技术这件事情上。
没有什么太大的一个思路。
那我觉得这套课程其实是有帮助的。
他至少比看扭车的这个书要好。
因为他那个书其实内容也很好。
但是真的太枯燥
太枯燥
哎 我给老潘这个内容。
再打一个更往前一点的前提。
就像刚刚白老师说的。
就是要知道自己拍什么？
其实我觉得入门阶段很核心。
很核心的一个问题。
包括在那个老潘说的那个扭车。
那个课非常使用
非常适合在入门的阶段去学习。
但那之前我觉得还有个大前提。
就是真的要知道自己喜欢拍什么？
就是或者说要确定一下。
自己真的喜欢拍摄。
因为如果很多人去看一看身边例子。
会发现很多人当时。
单反热潮的那一阵子。
很多人买完单反之后最后吃灰了。
因为单反其实当时很多人买。
你说这个钱也花的也不少。
但是买了一个大件回来。
最后自己没有能坚持下去。
我觉得这一点非常非常重要。
就是在那之前至少知道自己是。
持续的喜欢拍东西。
然后在这一点
是的
你会有去动力去学习这个技术。
我觉得这点比较重要一点。
没错没错
阿欣说这点我想到。
我身边也会有这样一类人。
有时候看到我拍的时候。
他会就说这有什么好拍的。
他们就给他不到那个。
想要拍照的那种
怎么说动力或者冲动。
他们会觉得这有什么好拍的。
是是是
你不用找好拍了
对吧？
给白老师都气出上海话了。
因为我这边在封业季的时候。
我也会跟同事说
我要去拍封业了
周末我要抓紧开车出去。
去山里面拍封业
他说
这有什么可以拍的。
为什么还要专门去拍这个。
对
对我就这个就
如果是这种心态
可能还没有能得到拍摄的一个乐趣吧？
是
说到这个我就想起一个故事。
然后我其实想在这里给大家撒一狗粮。
就是我有特别感谢我老婆。
就是我那个时候刚开始去摄影的时候。
比如说我去希腊玩。
我就真的会路过一个场景反复的拍。
就我今天路过他了。
我拍一下
我第二天又路过他了。
我还拍
第三天路过他了
但是其实我我老婆应该挺无语的。
就那个时候我也不太会拍人。
我也不太会拍他
我就是拍那种建筑。
然后海什么的
然后同一个场景反复反复的拍。
一直到最近我们在聊起这件事情的时候。
他才说
那会我也觉得你挺奇怪的。
这个场景怎么拍完。
拍不完就一直一直拍。
但他当时其实没有没有说。
没有打击我的这种热情。
没有说你干嘛？
这有什么好拍的
就我拍的时候他就一直在边上等我这样子。
因为很热嘛？
那个时候我记得40度40度得有。
然后我就在那拍
他就站在边上阴影一下。
然后他也不会催我。
所以我觉得还蛮感谢他。
没有在那个阶段把我的热情磨灭掉。
或者说没有打击我的热情。
行吧 今天七夕节。
就允许老潘长得空谅。
对 然后我觉得老潘这点。
因为我也非常认同。
因为我觉得喜欢拍照的人。
对 一个场景
他觉得任何十分都是不一样的。
都是想拍照
没错
对 就很神奇
因为我觉得光线不一样嘛？
对 就是不一样的。
早上和晚上就是不一样的。
中午也是不一样的。
下雨也有下雨的场景。
甚至你往前走一步。
往后走一步也不一样。
是 是
别人就会觉得
哎 这有什么好拍的。
对的
刚拍过吗？
不是 早上刚拍过吗？
不是 下雨天有什么好拍的。
对 所以在听的朋友们。
也是也希望我们这些节目。
能够帮助大家去
有这样子的一个想法。
就是我是喜欢摄影的。
所以我拍的任何东西。
对我来说都是有意义的。
你不用在意别人怎么说。
哎 这有什么好拍的。
这有什么意义
就这个世界不需要那么多意义。
我喜欢就好
好 那我们接着往下。
到了现在这个阶段。
我觉得我们都进步了一些。
相比起入门的阶段。
我们可以称之为一个。
进阶的阶段吧？
或者是线阶段
我们就不要给它下太多定义。
那在现在的话
你们还会自学吗？
然后如果你们还会自学。
你们是怎么学的
我现在的学习就是跟着老潘学。
老潘也太坚实了
非常直白的时候就是这么？
非常直白的时候就是这样。
但是老潘之后
然后以及做了播科。
认识了更多人之后。
发现自己的
其实还只是在停留。
在非常表面的一些东西。
比如说像观念
就是一个
其实是一个非常大的。
一个可以学的东西。
一个铺 一个尺子。
里面有很多东西都可以学。
我就只要你不知道的。
不知道自己喜不喜欢的。
都可以去尝试了解。
然后别人说的一个名词。
你是不知道的你就去查一查。
然后比如说
你要影响系统性的学。
那你一些历史
历史性的东西
历史的阶段
故事 发展
这个脉络
也可以学
那现在的学习
我觉得还是比较偏碎片式的。
因为一方面有工作。
工作之余
其实学习的动力
在没有那么大的情况下。
就是碎片式的
看到了一个就去查一下。
那就保持好奇
爱的
没错
我的进阶阶段到现阶段。
确实也是时间完全不够用。
所以说也是一样的。
偏向于碎片化学习为主。
其实我还挺羡慕老潘能够。
完整的系统性的去学习这个东西的。
我觉得
在一个现阶段
或者说是
当你已经打完了所有的基础的时候。
有这么一个
完整的系统的学习。
是非常非常有意义的。
但是礼于这个时间。
问题吧？
确实也没法实现
那么我觉得在
现阶段主要想提升的是。
审美和观念
就是很多人
我们能听得到在现阶段的时候。
大家都不会去讨论所谓的技术问题了。
因为这个东西应该是。
我个人认为吧？
在这个阶段应该是。
属于潜移默化或者说是跟。
自己的身体一部分一样。
这个相机或者说手上这个工具。
肌肉肌肌了
对
它已经不是一个需要特别考虑的一个点了。
应该就跟眼睛去看一样。
是习惯了
然后在进阶阶段的话。
我感觉就像是人打开了个天窗。
当你所有的技术都已经达到位了。
那你接下去就是像开了天眼一样的。
你所有的路前都可以走了。
比如说
你要看自己想要去拍摄的东西。
甚至说你去看历史书籍。
观察社会现状
这些东西都可以对应的拍摄。
有实质性的帮助
打开思路啊？
什么的
所以说我觉得更多的。
会去思考吧？
就是与其说是做一点实际上的什么样的事情。
我觉得在现阶段想的比以前更多了。
就是实践还是依然很重要的。
但是脑子中过的内容。
或者说是对这个照片本身的意义的探究。
会比以前花更多的时间去在这种事情上面。
明白明白
然后我自己的话呢？
就是我是刚结束了一整年的全日制的学习嘛？
但是我其实还是在会有一些自学的。
就是相比起入门阶段以技术为主的自学。
那现阶段的话对我来说。
可能自学的核心还是审美和观念的提升。
那其实方法就很简单。
就是通过不断的看划策和理论书籍。
然后自行去总结去思考。
然后去进行实践的尝试。
然后技术上的话呢？
其实通过这一年的学习。
我学会了一个技能。
就是通过项目去打磨技术的这种方式。
所以这是我目前去自学技术的方法。
然后除了此之外的话呢？
我觉得和一些摄影大师的日常的相处。
其实也是一种学习。
你可以去看到他们对于摄影的态度。
然后甚至有的时候一起去拍照的时候。
他们的拍摄方法
他们的一些投入的状态。
都是一些我在学习的东西。
然后包括做播客这件事情。
我觉得其实也是一个学习。
因为每一期节目开始录之前。
我们都要做准备嘛？
那有些节目我们可能要提前半个月。
甚至一个月开始就要做一些准备工作。
然后这些准备工作中。
其实就包括一些学习。
然后会去查资料
会去拍摄
然后会去看一看
有没有别人去讨论过这个话题。
然后别人是怎么说的。
或者有些书籍是怎么样的。
就一直会通过这种方式去学习。
所以我觉得做了这一年多的播客。
其实提升的也还蛮多的。
所以大家如果愿意做一些总结式的。
对吧？
我自己也觉得提升的蛮多的。
不管是说系统性的总结了。
自己的一些经验啊知识啊？
还是说去额外的去学习了一些。
曾经没有接触过的东西。
或者没有了解过的一些东西之外。
其实都是很有帮助。
所以大家如果愿意去做一些输出。
其实也不错
比如说谢谢公众号呀？
哪怕写小红书呀？
或者自己去做一个栏目啊？
其实可能都是在你进阶了以后。
能够帮助你去继续。
进行自学的一个比较好的方法。
妙哎
就是我一开始
我们一开始录的时候。
我在想就是输入
输入是一种学习
那老潘现在讲下来就是。
输出的过程也是一种学习。
很妙
对
因为你拍摄其实也是一种输出嘛？
你是把你脑子里面东西。
通过相机去表现出来了。
你去分享这些图片是一种输出。
然后如果你愿意做一些文字性的表达。
或者说是这种像我们做语言性的表达。
甚至于做视频
它其实都是一种学习的方法。
因为你不断的做的过程中。
你一定会不断的提高自己的。
因为如果你不提高。
你会遇到内容输出的瓶颈。
你会觉得我没东西可写了。
我没有话可说了
我没有东西可拍了。
然后反正这就是我自己现阶段的。
一些学习的方法
就是输入和输出并行。
我觉得在这个阶段。
其实就挺重要的了。
我们继续往下一个部分进行。
下面的话
我觉得我们可以给听友们分享一些。
如何高效的进行自学的一些经验和方法。
或者说我们在自学的过程中。
有没有一些小的技巧。
可以去跟别人分享。
对我来说的话
我觉得这个可能就分为。
观念和实践两个部分。
首先我会觉得说
在自学这件事情上。
一定要建立一个
属于自己的自学的逻辑和观念。
那我的观念就是
我很幸运的在开始学习的过程中。
就听到了一句话
我已经忘记是
是哪本书里的
是庄子还是什么？
还是循子之类的
然后其中有一句话叫做。
求其上者得其中
求其中者得其下
求其下者无所得
所以我从一开始就知道。
当我去学习的时候。
尤其是我自学的时候。
我就会把目标定得比较高。
我想去学习的这些人。
我想去学习的这些作品。
我想去学习的这些东西。
可能都是离我更远的。
然后离我的距离更遥远一些。
比如我目标设置的更大一些。
然后去看一些更好的东西。
真正的大师的作品。
真正的好的作品
真正的这些
让你觉得
我在这个阶段我可能达不到。
但是我愿意去尝试的东西。
而不是把眼睛放在身边的人。
比如说论坛啊？
或者是网红啊这些身上。
所以这是我最开始自学的时候。
我觉得就定好的一个方向。
那我觉得这件事情。
对我的帮助是很大的。
对我不知道你们会不会在学习的时候。
有这样子的一个观点。
其实老潘说的这个当中。
是刚刚有提到系统话。
我觉得这一点相当重要的。
就是如果说想要高校的。
或者说有效的去自学的话。
就像我刚刚说的
在第一步
如果你已经确定了解自己。
是喜欢拍照的
或者说是完全停不下来。
就是想要去拍摄的话。
那么比如说之前老潘学习的。
他都学的是很好的那种。
results
比如说是纽射
还有后面跟马格兰一起学习。
我觉得有一个系统性的学习。
绝对是效率提升的一个保障。
因为在系统的学习当中。
你可以知道你学习的这一点。
跟其他的有关部分。
互相起到什么联系。
会有什么帮助
这点可以让你就是对某样东西。
学习更加的深入
或者更加的有实际的意义。
比如说你的审美
和你的技术当中可以互相补足。
你了解技术是怎么样子。
去帮助审美进行提升的。
也可以了解到审美。
是通过什么样的技术。
去进行实现的
我觉得系统的话是。
在这个学习技巧当中。
是一个比较有意义的一个点吧？
同意
但是我在想
因为你们说到的系统话。
其实还是一个比较高的。
一个空的一个点
但落到每个人实际上。
就有个词叫音材师教嘛？
就每个人还是得找到。
自己的那条路
那我是想着说
是不是可以先定一个。
要达到的目标
就说我想达到
某某某拍成什么什么样。
然后再往前倒推
那如果我要达到那个。
我可以做什么？
所以白老师
我觉得你说的这个挺好的。
就是比如说这个目标。
也不一定要是一个。
特别高远的目标
它可以就是
我想拍一张这样的照片。
我如何能实现它
是不是
我觉得如果听有
就我们群里的听有。
它有这方面的疑惑。
它可以比如说私下。
或者群里来问说
如果我想拍成这样。
我大概要先练习哪些东西。
可能因为我觉得很多人。
他可能对这种
你说的说系统性的学。
他可能连系统
这个是什么都不知道。
有道理
我在想啊？
那既然这样
那我们先从
稍微小一点的目标。
我想拍成
我能够得到的
跳一跳能够得到的。
是一个什么东西
然后我
我开始练习如何去跳。
在一个个小的目标积累了。
完了之后可能
会到了老潘这样的一个。
嗯
阶段就说
哦
那我要进行一个
怎么怎么怎么样的。
一个系统性的学习。
我把老师说到这点。
我可以稍微补充一下。
刚才自己说的
是这样
呃
我觉得
与其说是
系统还有另外一种角度去解读。
就是不要只
专看一个点
比如说现在的网上。
能看到很多
审美提升
这样子的帖子
然后也许就有人
就会一直在看啊？
审美提升
今天了解一下这个。
明天了解一下那个。
都是大事
就陷进去了
但是呢？
自己又没有去注重。
实际上操作上的
一个练习
或者说是一个对器材的了解。
那么这就是有点偏科了。
或者也有一些
我们看到的器材党。
其实大家一开始
都是对摄影感兴趣。
那么最后为什么？
它会偏到器材党
对于审美可能又说啊？
我这个器材是最厉害的。
那么那个大师
这个那个又有什么意义。
这也是一种偏科
所以说应该
其实我比较
想说系统性是觉得说。
你的摄影
要学习要完整的学习。
对每一个方面都要同步进行。
这样子才不会偏科。
所以我觉得这点上。
我们给出的建议
其实是互相不矛盾的。
就是我的一个
核心的观点呢？
就是大家要把眼光放的。
更高远一些
更长远一些
去看一些更好的东西。
然后不要着眼于身边的人和事。
就是你能够接触到这些人和事。
然后阿星的观点呢？
其实就是完整的学习。
系统的学习
有一个框架和逻辑的去学习。
甚至于给自己制定。
一个学习的计划
然后白老师的想法就是。
我们要有一个
从一个个小目标开始。
这当然不是说
挣一个亿的小目标啊？
就我想拍
我想拍一张
怎样的照片
我想拍一个
怎么样的东西
我想实现
某一个小小的技术上的小突破。
对吧？
拆解成
一个一个的小的piece。
然后把它
全部一点一点去做出来。
最后拼成一张完整的拼图。
所以这其实是不猛的。
我永远是落地向的。
对 挺好的
那说到落地
我们就继续再往下落地一点。
我们能不能跟大家分享一些。
我们自学的时候的一些学习技巧。
那我觉得
我自己的一个
收集摄影的一些资源。
就是摄影学习一些资源的。
一个小方法
我觉得挺好的
就是我会用Google去。
Google的这个浏览器。
有一个Bookmark。
就是输签的功能
我会给这个输签做一个。
怎么说呢？
一个属于自己的一个。
摄影资料库
然后比如说
我喜欢的摄影师
我会给他们列出
一个输签的栏目
然后谁谁谁谁
可能有十几二十个摄影师。
那么他们的网站
就加在这个输签里面。
我会不定一区的去看。
然后有一些
有关于摄影比赛的。
或者是一些摄影奖项的。
那他可能是另外一个。
输签的这么一个标签。
里面有很多很多内容。
然后有一些博物馆的。
画廊的
美术馆的
他可能是一个标签。
然后一些有关于
摄影技术性的讨论。
或者是摄影伦理道德讨论。
或者是一些摄影其他方面。
讨论摄影室什么的。
那他可能又是另外一个标签。
就是我会分门别类的。
去整理我在网上看到的。
各种各样有关摄影的资料。
然后把它放在一个。
Bookmark的这个系统里面。
就建立了一个自己的资料库。
这个方法
我觉得其实是蛮好用的。
我觉得大家如果说。
感兴趣的话
愿意去做这样子的尝试。
可以试试看
老潘简直是自学的典范啊？
就是我是一个
比较有计划的人
就做事情上
可能所以在这些事情上。
会做的稍微细致一些。
然后除此之外的话。
我记得
听友还提到过一个问题。
他说他身处一个小县城。
那除了看纸质书
和相关视频之外
还有什么方法
能够缓解摄影焦虑。
那我自己的话呢？
其实是
我虽然我很喜欢
去买摄影书
然后收集摄影书
看画册
理论书也是
但是我其实很能理解说。
如果我没有这样子的条件。
去购买或者说
没有时间
没有这个
经历
去买实体书
可能也不是很方便。
那我怎么去看摄影作品。
我自己也有一些小的经验分享。
那比如说
你可以去找一些
你喜欢的这种摄影机构的网站。
网站是最好的方法。
你只要这个地方能连网。
哪怕你别说
身处小县城了
在村子里
它只要有网
你就能干那事情
去看
这种图片社机构
比如说马克南
比如说UV
比如说这些图片社。
可以去看
然后画廊
比如说我特别喜欢的。
Francon Gallery。
然后你可以去看
它带来了很多的艺术家。
每个艺术家都有自己的主页。
然后看他们的这个作品。
他们也会更新
他们正在拍摄的一些项目。
一些内容
一些画廊的网站
可不仅仅是说
就是提供一些展讯。
它实际上是有很多的艺术家的一些作品籍。
什么可以去看的
那还有就是摄影师的个人网站。
你喜欢的这些摄影师。
只要它是稍微有点明知明度的。
你都能找到它的个人网站。
你去google上搜就好了。
顶多搭个梯子
对吧？
去搜一下
然后这些网站的内容。
就足够你去看很久很久。
然后足够你去看很多很多了。
所以这些
其实是在摄影书和画册之外。
你可以去学习摄影掌握。
这些去看到这些资料的方法。
看到这些图片资料也好。
看到这些内容的方法。
然后还有一个的话。
就是我觉得在资学摄影上。
建立项目概念其实很重要。
你一旦建立了项目概念。
你可以通过这个项目的概念。
去像阿兴说的一样和白二说。
其实都是一样
就是你无论你是按照一个piece。
一个piece的小拼图。
去拼成一个结构
还说你先有一个完整的概念。
然后去填充它
它都可以去完成
有了一个摄影项目的概念。
你会通过拍摄这个项目的过程中。
不断的去打磨自己的技巧。
提高自己的审美
然后提高自己的意识。
所以它是很重要的。
所以这三点就是
我自己觉得我在学习。
这个资学摄影上的一些。
小小的落地性的技巧。
能够帮助到大家的。
也许
然后看看可以听白老师和阿兴怎么说。
管了
我觉得老潘已经说得挺全了。
我就专门抢别人话。
走别人的路
让别人无路可走
那我再补充两个小点。
一个是我自己也会额外做的。
因为老潘刚刚说的就是。
之前我也看老潘的直播。
发现建立Bokumak这些。
非常实用
完全值得大家学习。
这个非常有用的
然后在此之外呢？
我还有一个建议
就是大家可以经常回顾自己的照片。
就是隔着时间
比如说一年以前拍的。
两年以前拍的
就是时不时的建议。
大家拿出来
不是说自我欣赏
自我感叹一下
哎呀？
自己真强
而是就是看
看得真好
而是看看
现在的审美
自己现在的阶段
看过去的照片
能感觉到什么？
认为这些照片
他还有自己的表达在当中吗？
他还好吗？
自己心中认为这样的照片。
自己还想留着吗？
就像之前老潘其实也提到过。
这个就是之前有个。
一年五十张照片的那个方法是吗？
就是还挺有效的
对
一直回顾自己
就是把这个照片
在自己的脑中
一直轮转滚过去
我觉得这点是非常有用的。
就是要复盘和反思自己过去的。
拍摄的照片
对
如果你看自己半年前。
或者一年前的照片。
没有觉得说
你现在有进步了
那可能就是要调整一下。
学习的方法了
以我自己的感觉就是。
我看半年前一年前的照片。
当然这个不是固定的。
就我可能现在在看。
半年前的照片
我觉得可能还好
但是在一年前
我在去看一年两年前的照片。
或者说怎么样
你就会觉得好像那个时候拍的。
确实不太行
就是你如果能够
持续的感觉到自己的进步。
就说明你的自学
是在一个正确道路上的。
如果你一直没有太多进步的话。
你觉得好像我去年跟前年。
没有什么区别
前年跟大前年也没有什么区别。
那可能就要考虑一下。
是不是需要去调整一些了。
还有一个点就是
不一定对所有人都适用。
就是花钱
不是那种我们想的买器材什么的。
就是可能有一部分人会觉得说。
我去买摄影的画册。
或者说去看摄影展这件事情。
是一个没有什么必要花的钱。
但我觉得这一点还是挺有意义的。
因为我认为它是一种保持自己。
对于摄影的一种
联系或者说是感觉的一种方式。
就是通过这样子的一个氛围感。
比如说你很有仪式感的买了一本。
很透重的摄影书
回来看画册
或者说去参与亲身去看一下这个影展。
他们都能大幅的增强。
你跟拍摄这件事情联系。
因为在很多人可能说。
我现在技术都会了。
我都知道怎么拍摄。
我想拍的照片了
过段时间我觉得
现在忙了又没什么？
跟摄影本身联系有不大的时候。
去参与一下
它能够把自己拉回来。
拉回到一个摄影的一种状态。
我觉得就是
这个能够时不时的提醒自己。
继续去激励自己往前进。
我觉得这也挺有用的。
对 但是如果说像刚才那位朋友。
我们提到的之前也挺有提到。
他说他说伸出小千层。
他可能没法看窄
那其实也没有关系。
就可以把这些东西电子化。
现在是有很多的线上资料。
可以去看的
甚至有很多线上导来。
你可以去看到一些展览的东西。
只要你愿意花时间去找。
你一定能够找到
适合你学习的资源。
我在听你们讲的时候。
我就突然有个点冒出来了。
我其实非常赞同的一个点。
就是摄影是一定要落地的。
但在没有每天都可能。
在相机的时候
有没有可能保持一个。
手机拍摄的一个习惯。
但因为我知道
老拍是不太会用手机拍的。
但我现在我自己
如果说不是每天
带相机的情况下
我碰到想拍的
我可能会先用手机打个样。
就保持一个
愿意拍摄的冲动
是学习的一个
什么说前动力吧？
就是持续的拍摄
你只要还愿意拍
你就会愿意学
你这个我同意
如果你连拍都不太想拍了。
我就想着就不用再谈学了。
同意
对
可能就得缓缓了
保持着一个拍
哪怕没有相机就用手机。
保持着一个心思一个动作。
就说你可能手机拍摄。
是打不到相机拍摄的那个效果的。
但你可以对自己
喜欢的一个场景先打个样。
这个也是可以
因为这个是我自己。
实际会做的一个事情。
手机拍照先打个样。
大概知道一下
这样的一个场景
甚至会出什么样的照片。
或者说白老师说的。
其实是保持一个以摄影的方式。
去观察世界的能力。
和这种敏感度吧？
没错
我和阿欣不是一直说。
因为自己在工作中。
有时候会忙于工作。
疏忽了拍照这个事情吗？
那可能拍照的动作。
在我们现在的阶段。
是一个低电量
在运行的一个模式。
但不能断开跟它的连接。
但是要保持这个低电量依然存在。
对
低电量你就保持这么一个动作。
不管怎么样手机拍一张。
然后以后就会想到说。
我拿起相机之后
我这个感觉上不会生疏掉。
然后保持拍摄的动作。
对
不要断电
保持拍摄的动作
就会有持续的力量去学习。
同意
好的
那我们下一个问题。
下一个问题的话
我觉得我们可以再跟大家去分享一下。
我们自己有没有在自学中踩过坑。
就是听我们节目的。
听我们能不能通过这些节目。
避开一些小小的自觉的坑。
我觉得我自己遇到的最大的一个坑。
是出自自己的问题的。
就是太自大自满了。
有一阵子就是
比如说
这个问题很容易出现在拍摄。
我自己的例子吧？
就是很容易出现在拍摄。
声控这些事情上面。
因为自己拍到了
好像大家平时拍不到的东西。
就觉得自己已经天下无敌了。
然后就会守的这些照片。
觉得自己已经没有对手了。
那种感觉
一旦开始雇步自封了。
就思想上面就有一种一把锁。
就让自己去停止自己学习了。
觉得自己好像在方面不需要什么提升了。
或者说我已经已经到顶了那种感觉。
觉得自己特别厉害。
但其实你回过头来看还是非常的幼稚的。
然后东西也非常的空洞。
所以说我觉得最大的坑就是对于自己。
非常的自满
我觉得这一点还是挺大一个坑。
确实确实
就是摄影这个东西吧？
你他不像考试
你有一个标准答案。
你能有一个分数
我可能90分100分。
我就最好了
摄影它毕竟还是艺术形式。
所以其实很难有一个说。
我已经达到了一个完美的状态。
或者是最好的状态。
它一定是需要不断的进步。
就一定要以开放的心态去面对。
这个世界或者是摄影的世界。
就是你总会看到更好的东西。
然后总会看到让自己羡慕的东西。
然后你才会不断的往上走。
这样
对
然后我自己在摄影中采过的坑。
就是我买过一些特别离谱的摄影胶层。
就我不知道大家有没有在网上。
搜过一些摄影教材类的书籍。
比如说什么都什么怎么拍。
然后这样子的书籍。
我在最开始自学摄影的阶段。
我除了这个现场课之外。
我还想看一些书
我就去买了一些这些书。
我觉得真的就特别离谱。
你会发现它里面讲的东西。
你现在在想想看
你觉得都不可思议。
它跟你讲的是
别说是参数对不对了。
就是很多的基础的逻辑都不正确。
所以这个事我可能采过一些比较大的坑。
我是觉得我们买摄影书。
我们可以把钱投在画册上。
可以把钱投在这种文献上。
或者说是这种理论书上。
但是不要去买书面的摄影教材。
尤其是一些你听都没有听过的摄影教材。
我会告诉你进入摄影怎么拍。
然后什么什么？
50张照片
50张大片
然后这些大片是怎么拍的。
这种类型的书
我觉得必坑真的必坑。
真的没有用
就真的特别水
我不知道这些书是怎么出版的。
我到现在都不能够理解。
就真的不太懂
不过没错摄影类教材书籍。
可能是我见过在书店里面。
水平最为层次不起的一类书籍了。
我觉得
真的
当然不是说所有都不好。
确实还是有好的
比如说我知道有一个系列。
标题特别土
但是内容很好
什么拍出绝世光线。
然后什么什么名
这个就名字特别特别土。
我都忘记是谁写的出了。
也是一个国外的摄影师写的。
好像
但它里面内容很好。
它里面内容对于这个基础特别扎实。
然后写的特别好
我之前也看过
所以我觉得还是要分辨一下。
就不能说一棒的打死摄影教材都不好。
但是确实挺层次的。
像阿星说的
你可能还是最好能够去线下翻一翻。
看看这个内容好不好。
再决定要不要购买。
反正我是买到过一些特别离谱的书。
那我这边就先推荐大家听一下。
我们去年
23年7月31号路过的一期。
摄影学习中存在多少弯路和物区。
是
去回听的期播课
我们有特地了解一下这些东西。
这些坑
是
我觉得采
我觉得提一点
采坑不是一件坏事。
你同意
就是其实采坑也是一种经历。
也是你自己去学习的一个过程。
哪怕我觉得是
有些人
头铁说
我都试试看
然后
我觉得说不定也是。
可能是一种更快的成长。
我觉得不采坑
说不定还
成长不起来
对
这个就我也同意
是有可能的
那
换句话说
那我们刚说采过的坑。
就像白耳说的坑
其实不见得说是
不应该采的
或者说是绝对不能采的。
那我们换一个角度来说。
你们在摄影中
自学摄影的过程中。
有没有什么？
特别庆幸自己做对的事情呢？
我想的就是
你哪怕进步慢一点。
都不要着急
我昨天跟我的朋友录。
那个Lomo的那期的时候。
我们也在
讲到一个事情
就说
热爱是一切事情的原动力。
没错
所以
我觉得在摄影这个。
很万斤有的事情上。
就保持这份热爱
然后
我们昨天其实有分享到说。
如果你一个人的能量长。
非常低
那你做任何事情
它都不会持续得很久。
但如果你能在这种。
一个事情上
获得一个比较高的能量。
那
哪怕你现在收
没有获得很多的正能量。
但是从长远的角度来说。
还是会
是一个往上走的阶段。
所以我觉得
不要让摄影拖累自己。
享受这个过程
我觉得会是一个持续往上走的。
如果你已经到了说。
哎呀？
这个有什么好拍的这种心情。
那就不拍了吧？
我说说我自己庆幸做的事情。
最主要的就是没有把自己。
留存在某个特定的圈子里面。
对
就是我
虽然我刚刚举了例子。
就是踩过的坑
就是因为拍摄了
星眼啊？
星空啊什么的
感觉自己很厉害
但是
不是说一直就是沉浸在这里面啊？
我觉得庆幸的就是。
我什么话题
什么的内容都感兴趣去拍。
比如说我们
总说的老法师专属的题材拍鸟。
我也拍过
然后所有的风光人。
我觉得这一点
很重要就是要什么都感兴趣。
我就特别感谢自己是没事。
就会把时间浪费在这个看杂书的这件事情上面。
就是我的
感觉自己这身边非常的杂。
虽然没有这么深吧？
这个
不能算好事
但是我觉得杂
对于摄影来说
本质上也算是一件好事。
就是你所有
能拍的能表达的
想拍的东西就会非常的多。
那这样的话
最重要的一点就是没有把你。
最终锁在某一个特定的内容里面。
我觉得这一点对于拍摄的广度。
应该是很有帮助的。
那么深度可能就是要。
你自己思想上进一步挖掘去挖掘深度。
但是我觉得广度不应该有所欠缺。
就是你要了解过自己所有能够试过的。
才会发掘出自己真正适合的。
想要拍的东西
不过你可以把摄影比做一整个游戏。
一整个人生就是
建议大家都去尝试一下。
就咱们这个是一个很个人的。
就是亲信自己做过做对的事情。
就我们的这些经历。
不见得能够被耗用在各位听友的身上。
就是完全是从个人角度出发。
你觉得自己庆幸的一件事情。
是你今天回头看的时候觉得。
我这个做得没错
我觉得就可以了
我觉得我就是保持一个很低的喜欢。
但是一直持续着很久。
把时间性拉得更长。
对
我其实对摄影没有那么大的。
非常巨大的恶情
但是就是一直做一直在拍。
因为我看到很多
就是很多年轻的就是什么9495。
或者说才开始拍的。
其实已经取得了很大成就的。
我感觉我好像达不到。
他们那种那么高的成就。
但是我还是庆幸的说。
自己还是爱干这件事情。
也许只是白老师的成就。
还没有来而已
不见得说是
这个我觉得这年龄没有关系。
那安多瓦达他
他可是从30岁才开始摄影的。
在40岁才开始摄影。
还不是30岁
在接近40岁才开始拍照。
除了我自己
我觉得我做得很庆幸。
自己做对的一件事情。
就是我没有相信某网红课程。
这种呼伦吞噪的方法。
就当时我在报纽射这个现场课之前。
其实为什么我会想到。
想去上一上课呢？
就是因为我老婆在听一个摄影课。
我之前节目里面有讲过应该。
就是是一个讲进入摄影的课程。
大家可能都知道
还挺火的有一段时间。
那她在听的时候
我就在边上跟着听了一会。
我就听到她讲一个拍摄。
她就说你别管为什么？
你就这么拍
光圈就是这样
块本就是这样
然后ISO怎么设置。
你就这么拍
你别问为什么？
你不需要知道
所以我当时就很庆幸的一件事情。
是我没有觉得这种快速入门。
确实它的方法好在哪里。
好在你可以迅速获得成就感。
我们现在看到的不少的这个网红摄影师。
都是用这一套方法去拍摄的。
你是可以看得出来的。
所以他们特别是拍进物的这些人。
你会看到他们拍的就是这一套东西。
他可以迅速的让你去获得。
一些还不错的照片。
但是我觉得我当时很庆幸。
就是我不相信这套方法。
我是很坚持
只其然一定要只其所以然的。
所以我在选择课程的时候。
我找了纽射的这套。
很慢
但是基础还不错的课程。
而没有选择这种
胡轮吞噪的网红方式。
这个我觉得挺庆幸的。
那说到这里既然说到这个课程的话。
我也正好想问一下两位。
你们如何看待各种各样的摄影课。
你们最有上过摄影课吗？
我自己没有上过摄影课。
从来没有上过
那阿兴呢？
我也没上过
看你们都
所以只有我上过课吗？
对
我去下来是
准确地说我看过个教程。
但是没有正儿八经的上过课程。
对
因为我其实还蛮喜欢上课的。
所以我上过一些不同的摄影课。
学习选手
对
我是觉得其实挺不错。
而且我自己还做过摄影课。
就我后来跟蔡司签约之后。
给蔡司做过这个蔡司学院。
然后做过基础课
做过这种训练营的课程。
然后我自己现在还在涉及一套新的课程。
就是有关于个人项目的。
但是因为经历有限。
所以只做的小规模很小。
只能接受十来个人的这样子的一个规模。
所以我自己也会做一些摄影课程。
所以我其实挺相信摄影课程的这个东西。
但是确实就是在整个的摄影课程有很多。
然后有很层次
要选择合适的摄影课程其实挺难的。
那既然两位没有上过课程。
那我就不为乃两位。
就我自己给大家做一个课程的推荐。
我本来想问问看两位。
有没有什么可以推荐的课程给大家。
那就是我来简单说一下。
简单的话
我都不知道该怎么接了这个话题。
首先就是入门阶段。
如果你真的想上课。
我觉得你可以去试试看纽设的课程。
当然前提是你英文要稍微好一些。
这是一个
然后如果说你过了这个阶段。
你现在进阶的阶段。
我很推荐你去试试看马格兰的线上课。
马格兰是有一套online课程的。
然后都是这些摄影师来讲。
但他们其实这些课程做的也很精美。
但它里面实际是没有任何技术性的东西的。
它完全只有关于观念和概念。
所以这个是进阶的阶段会比较适合的。
在马格兰官网就可以去购买。
我觉得整套课程做的质量都非常的好。
所以这个就是可以覆盖掉。
你在入门阶段和进阶阶段可能会需要的课程。
那当然你也可以选择一些你自己喜欢的摄影师的课程。
比如说像我会有比较固定的学员。
然后他们会
就我之前一直做课程他们都会一直参加。
然后就你要找到适合你自己的风格和方法的这些课程。
那我会比较偏理论。
然后会比较偏向于说一定要把这个问题讲清楚。
那有些人可能会更加的高效一些。
然后有些人的课可能会更加涉及某一个专业的领域或者方向。
那你可以通过这个角度去寻找一些课程。
然后比如说你对后期感兴趣可以找一些感兴趣的后期课。
那这里我们就不做更多的推荐了。
就是我自己会比较推荐大家比较通用的。
每个人都可以去试试看的。
就是纽舍的和马格兰的这两套线上课。
其实是挺好的
那接下来因为我们这期节目是由三位听友的提问而形成的。
我们刚刚讲的这些内容是不是已经回答掉他们的问题了。
呃两位可以看看有没有什么想要补充的。
我可以单独回应一下坤的问题。
就是说他的问题是。
作为刚开始接触摄影的爱好者。
总觉得网上九攻阁对角线的教程不是摄影该追求的。
但作为刚刚接触的自学者。
又不知道怎么通过相对正规的方式提升。
那么有什么不同的途径方法吗？
其实我想说
呃就像之前说到的。
没有摄影这件事情本身很多时候并没有所谓的正规。
或者说是正统
这些
摄影真正的照片好的照片。
他并不一定是通过一个某种框架去固定的框架去得到的。
所以说我认为最好的学习方式还是把这个基础打好。
比如说可以推荐一下老潘刚说的扭射的这个线上课程。
或者说是这种比较通用型的。
把自己的基础全部打好之后去发现自己的。
喜欢的拍摄的方式。
因为我们看其实之前的节目当中也做过好几期大师访谈嘛？
不同的大师或者说不同的拍照好的人。
他自己的照片其实并没有固定的逻辑。
并不是说每一个大师大家都有相似的所谓的构图的方式。
或者说是构图的一个规律。
主要还是通过自己的表达。
所以说我认为想说好摄影就是把基础全部打好之后。
自由的去发挥自己。
并没有一个固定的或者说是正统的一个拍摄的方式。
嗯 同意
因为摄影从根源上说它是一种语言。
其实我想问一下这位昆王。
因为他说总觉得网上那些九宫阁对角线的教程。
不是摄影应该追求的。
那什么是摄影应该追求的呢？
我这个是一个疑问句啊？
不是说反问句问你。
但是我觉得他的这个思路其实挺好的。
就是他已经觉得说这种九宫阁对角线的方法。
不是应该追求的
就一认为就其实他心里面是有知道摄影到底他想追求什么的。
或者说哪怕说不是说应不应该追求。
而是他自己知道自己想要追求的不是这些东西。
那是不是可以就是两条推走路吗？
那就是两边都尝试一下。
那九宫阁是不是一个对于摄影基础的构图上的一个指导。
只说这伟坤他在跳出了摄影基础的学习之后。
他觉得其实可以有更好的一个构图的指导。
对其实是这样子
就是九宫阁也好对角线也好什么三分线也好。
这些方法都是在最初期最初期。
能够迅速的去提高摄影二号者的拍照成功率的一个方法。
就最开始如果你没有这些方法的话。
你会就是说你会很难去在一开始就拍出。
让自己满意的照片。
你可能会在自信心上受到一些打击。
就拍出来怎么样都不好看或者怎么样。
但这些方法其实是很快让你能够有一个最基本的。
我拍出来这样照片觉得好像还可以。
这样子的一个也不能说捷径吧？
他是一个小技巧
但是这些技巧在后来。
当你有了一定的基础之后。
他就不再是一个我要实现的目标。
或者说我要去追求的东西了。
所以我觉得坤的这个意思应该是这样子。
我已经拖累了这些段之后。
我知道了他不是应该追求的。
那我现在有点不知道我该追求什么？
或者是我也不知道。
我该用什么方法去追求那些我想追求的东西。
那我在想
那坤是不是可以看到那些不属于。
九宫阁对角线的拍摄之后。
比如说把他们都收集起来。
然后去模仿自己觉得能拍到的照片呢？
可以
但单从说
单从说构图这一件事情来说。
除了白老师刚说的这个。
你去收集照片来总结的方法之外。
你可以去看一本书叫做摄影构图学。
是一本非常老
但是非常好的书
他在里面非常清楚地讲了。
有关于摄影构图的一些基础概念。
这个概念不是从技巧上进行的。
而是说我们为什么要构图。
从这个角度去进行。
然后如果你有了这个最基础的。
对于构图的认识之后。
你是能够找到构图的一些方法的。
我觉得这本书我可以推荐一下。
然后如果你是在我们群里的听友的话。
你也可以来问我要一下。
我是有一个电子版的。
可以跟你分享一下。
好了
那还有咕噜的问题刚刚没有提到。
咕噜说大家是怎么提升自己摄影技术的。
我们就单独不回答你了。
不是
这个叫什么？
没有提到你或者没有看到你的问题。
而是我们这期节目就是来了。
大家如何提升自己的摄影技术。
或者说如何自学摄影。
那我们今天节目要么就到这里。
我觉得差不多了
那感谢各位听我的收听。
也欢迎大家加入我们的社群。
来和我们一起聊摄影。
我们下期节目再见。
拜拜
下期见